Now,
I mean with what call me is doing and and you know John Jones coming back
dinner,
the lightweights are all moving up to heavyweight.
Do you think,
you know,
gone are the days of the huge dude who was just a physical phenom and now the
smaller technical dues is,
is that there's a thought
with the 265 pound weight class and the consensus thought seems to be that
somewhere around 240 pounds is the magic number.
That's what they think.
They think that 240 pounds is the amount of weight that you have where you're
strong enough that you can knock out any man,
right?
But you have more endurance than a man that may be ways to 65 or heavier and
cuts down to two 65 now this is not been substantiated.
The problem is there hasn't been a really super powerful world championship
athlete that weighed 265 pounds.
There's been Brock Lesnar,
but
Brock Lesnar's enhanced.
You're dealing with a guy who tested positive for steroids.
He probably has had things and then this is a new world.
He's also 40 years old now so it's impossible to tell what he would have been
like at 30 if he was clean.
And then you have guys like Francis and Ghana who was 265 pounds,
massive knockout artists,
natural 265 pounds but doesn't have the wrestling base,
got exposed in his fight with Steve Bay meo chick and you can't knock you out.
He's kind of doomed any tired out after the first round.
Okay,
so the,
it's hard to say cause there's never been a 265 pound version of Cain Velasquez,
Cain Velasquez.
My humble opinion when I look at all of the different heavyweights that I've
personally seen,
fight cane stands out as the best.
The reason why Keynes stands out as the best is because he has super human
endurance and his ability to put a pace on guys.
You would see these guys just wilt under the pressure of,
and I think with Cain and this is where it gets really interesting what did him
in is probably what also brought him to the top is his mental toughness because
his body started breaking down and he started having all these back injuries.
He needed back surgery,
multiple back surgeries,
shoulder surgery,
knee surgery,
everything was getting fucked up and I think it was getting fucked up cause he
was working through pain and because he has the ability to tolerate pain than
most people don't have and he's just a fucking animal.
But that's also probably what led to him having this insane endurance is the
same kind of mental toughness.
I'm sure there's some genetic advantages as well because they would talk about
how he would take months off and come back in and still fuck everybody up
because he's just that good.
But that also could be attributed to the,
the cardio base that he had from competing for many,
many,
many years at a high level and being known for that insane endurance
and perception to fatigue.
Going back to what you said,
if you could quantify that,
you'd put cane up there with one of those people.
Yes.
He has that in abundance.
Yeah.